Fun fact.
Our brain is so afraid of being
blamed for things that it will
bend time to stop
it from happening.
I'm Anthony.
This is D News.
And how we perceive
time is connected
to all kinds of things.
How quickly parts of our
brain can communicate
with each other, our
emotional state, our age.
And now, it turns out, our fear
of getting blamed for stuff.
Sense of agency is
basically your sense
that something you do causes
a change in the outside world.
So flip a light
switch, light goes on.
You go, hey, I did that!
Agency!
Please actually scream that when
you flip a switch from now on.
And a new study
shows that the type
of result that you
get from your action
can actually change your
perception of time and mess
with your sense of agency.
Researchers had
a group of people
press a series of buttons.
Some would give
positive feedback,
some would emit terrible noises.
And when the outcome
was good, the subjects
thought that it happened the
moment they pressed the button.
And when the button press
caused a bad outcome,
the subjects thought
there was a slight delay
between their button
press and the result.
The catch?
Every outcome happened
at the exact same speed.
Your brain speeds up
your perception of time
when you get a good
result, because you
want to feel directly
connected to it.
When your actions
have negative results,
your brain spaces the
cause and effect out.
You're trying to distance
yourself from responsibility.
If you push a button and then
slightly later a horrible siren
bothers everyone, I mean,
you just pushed a button.
The button made the noise.
Your mind is shielding you
from the stress and the guilt
associated with doing
something wrong.
Now the downside of this is
that your brain could literally
trick you into
thinking you weren't
responsible for
something when you were.
It also partially
explains why people
are so quick to take credit
for something positive,
and deny involvement
in something negative.
It's kind of like how
we go from, "No no!
I walked away before the
glass got knocked over.
I couldn't have broken
it." to, "No, that's mine.
I called it first.
I called it way before you."
And of course, some people
are just cowardly jerks.
Science still can't
explain cowardly jerks.
I feel like I've been
letting my brain fool me
into not taking the
blame for a lot of stuff.
How about you?
Has your brain been
letting other people
take the fall for your actions?
Let me know down below, and
subscribe for more D News.